jol herzlich willkommen wir haben heute
etwas ganz besonderes vor und zwar
vergleichen wir diese drei euro und ja
die kostet 13 euro ich habe dir auf
einmal zum gefunden ihr seht hier werden
bild absolut genial ich wusste das ist
so günstige mäuse gibt wir vergleichen
diese maus mit einer 70 euro gaming maus
die ich von mir habt danke an der stelle
auf jeden fall trocken auf sind möglich
an die ostsee ganz schön hier ist ist
alter die county mond wie sie da hier
bin ich dem ich habe hier auch malkurse
und fordern sie leuchtet und das ist
natürlich ein geiles vatikan die hier
hat kann im august das wird schon
interessant und wir testen die beiden
häuser heute im duell gegen tobi leute
was geht
thomas hat verkannt meine stimme
aufzunehmen deswegen übernehmen ist die
computerstimme einfach ich bin total
thomas wasser ist wenigstens die
männliche stimme
meinst du mich ja natürlich weiß ich
allerdings letzte alter kommt bruder
also ich habe jetzt mal die maut
ausgepackt die ist hier eine wunderbar
edlen verpackung angekommen absolut gar
dass wir haben hier aber die maus und
wir haben kabel und ich würde behaupten
um herauszufinden ob man mit dieser drei
es auch wirklich spielen kann ob
irgendwas topf linda ich hiermit guckt
alter für die packung dreht sich jetzt
einmal im eins-gegen-eins-duell mit
dieser maus an und danach mit dieser
maus und dann sehen wir ob wir das alter
[ __ ] leeren reden junge und dann sehen
wir auf die masse dann würde ich sagen
wir starten mit welchem aus fängst du an
mit der guten okay das bloß
ich mach dich fertig jetzt weiß man auch
was ich gelernt habe aber ich habe dann
gebaut
meine kleine schwester hat angst von ihr
in wort nicht so gut bin ich du bist weg
hasta la vista baby
ich bin ich bin also gut du weißt dass
ich besser bin oder
naja und wifi kirsten schaffst du mehr
als du juli lag okay let's go wir machen
jetzt averesch
nicht man leute ich schwöre ich konnte
das mal die sich als bau formation die
du kannst schmerzhaft bruder ich kann
drei kirschtorten in einer minute
verdrücken war also gar nicht ok krass
belastend ok es genoss die tour
gestartet mit al gore
wenn die mal war gar nix hey natürlich
junger gesund junge das schmeckt den
papa es wäre richtig spannend jetzt es
wird so spannend wie viel besser ich
aber sein werde mit der drei euro aus
ich werde deine ihre essen wie ein glas
guten ank
und das wieder über mir und yamaha vor
dieser szene hätte trends halter 22
belastend bist du runter gefallen ja das
ist aber dass gerade zu 3
erkennst du dich hätten müssen 4 zu 3
das war so wenn wir mit dieser erste
runde mit der gaming maus jetzt erst
noch mal die anderem aus ich glaube wir
dann deutlich gewonnen wir gucken jetzt
mal ob wir überhaupt mit der maus ein
bisschen dagegen ankämpfen können oder
ob wir uns da direkt fertig machen wir
also die mauer
wie gesagt folgendermaßen aus und wie es
die gegner also die funktioniert halt
schon also dies hat nicht schlecht wenn
man hat jetzt keine kohle hat tue jetzt
mal ehrlich was denkst du was sind jetzt
heißen kann deine eigene ehre kannst du
reißen
das ding ist dies im haushalt so leicht
dass in der luft war das kabel die maus
in die luft drückt genau so wie ich 100
kilo hantel bank in die luftbrücke
männer kann ich überhaupt einen thriller
nein hitzig treffen nichts
oh mein gott da hätte ja und nein
schmeckt nichts will dich kaputt land
aber dicker diesem aus es ist halt echt
schon geil dass man überhaupt einem
ausblick wird drei euro das sind ganzen
anderes gefühl
er fliegt er weiß dass ich nicht treffen
würde junge mann hatte überhaupt kein
gefühl mit diesem aus man hat junge mann
hat überhaupt keinen viele kinder aus
und so klar hin alle du kannst dich
vorschlag einen dienst wie der psv auf
oder so ähnlich verkrampft so die ganze
zeit voll ich habe keine es kam nie mehr
aber ich mache jetzt mit dem sieg habe
ich gesagt ich werde das ganze auch noch
auf jeden fall wiederholt günstigen
tastatur austesten hat schon etwas zu
bestellen haben wir fünf euro tastatur
wird das 180 euro ist würde ich hier am
start hat und dann auch mit so toby und
dann auch auf jeden fall mit einer mit
dem ein euro headset das die 280 euro
jetzt wird das headset
also ich hab ja nichts ich keine
neuwahlen
man muss einfach bei einer falle auf die
andere seite gehen dann treffe ich den
nicht privaten bist du das ding ist die
maus rtl geht ab und zu mal über schnell
und langsam du zwei faden wieder war es
ein erstes hallo du und ich schaffe das
noch was auch nächste entscheidest du
alter sagt der war schmerzhaft
[Musik]
er hat selber gesagt ja das war es auf
jeden fall mit dem video so wir haben
auf jeden fall gezeigt dass die maus
obwohl sie so günstig ist absolut
scheiße es hätte das gedacht also da wär
echt keiner drauf gekommen leute das hat
ja von diesem video hofft auf jeden fall
sinnvoll wenn es dann 15 euro tastatur
gegen 200.000 euro gaming tastatur sowie
thomas weh dass mir scheiße
synchronisiert wir dass die sache wie
ausgenutzt und keine ahnung was viel
spaß haut rein und gummi
da wären wir wieder bei vielen dank dass
du dabei warst und dann will behaupten
wenn ihr bock habt nicht ob diese reise
zu begleiten
dann abonniert doch diesen kanal und
dann sehen wir mal wieder nachts
gestoppt
[Musik]